how many of you would like to be the
reason someone succeeds in their life
today I want to share a few stories with
you that reveal an important truth about
success and the key to how you can be
the reason for the success of others my
first story is about my friend Jake it's
graduation day at UC Berkeley and Jake
is practically dancing his way up the
stage to get his bachelor's degree in
International Studies with honors his
parents are overjoyed they dreamed of
this day when they immigrated from
Poland all those years ago but the days
that followed were not as cheerful Jake
had been accepted to a top master's
program but in order to go you had to
secure funding so he spent this summer
applying to fellowships and trying to
come up with the money for school but by
August he was still short so he decided
to postpone grad school and look for a
good job but good jobs were scarce for
college grads in 2010 so after a few
months of disappointment with expenses
piling up and loans coming due he packed
up his bags moved back in with his
parents and took on a job selling movie
tickets for 8 bucks an hour
Jake's story is not unique
it's not even rare half of American
college graduates are underemployed
these are bright young educated people
whose potential is being wasted because
they believed in this model of success
they are taking on jobs that do not
require a college degree mainly to pay
for that degree because they grew up in
a society that told them follow your
passion and as long as you work hard and
you persevere you will succeed but that
is not true and now they feel betrayed
and lied to by a society that told them
they could make it because they didn't
but how can I say this here this is the
Stanford GSB this is a room full of
people who worked hard and made it yes
we are the other half and what separates
us from them is it just hard work and
perseverance no I don't think so there's
something more to success that hard work
and perseverance which brings me to my
second story my story
I started UC Berkeley around the same
time as shake at this point I had lived
in the US for about three years my
parents wanted me to stay in New York
Brad family or move back to Iran to live
with them but I had been accepted to
Berkeley and I know it's blasphemy to
say this here but I thought it was a
great school I really wanted to go there
young foolishness but I had to figure it
out on my own I had to become
financially independent and put myself
through school if I were to do this so I
decided to go and I have financial aid
and I thought I'd take a job and obz but
a few months in I got a letter in the
billing office
Yoda school $20,000 and out-of-state fee
and your financial aid does not cover it
so pay us out-of-pocket basically
I felt confused at first and then angry
and then helpless how could this be
happening I had taken a big step towards
independence I was going to put myself
through school but $20,000 how was I
going to come up with that on my own I'm
19 but I wanted to I was determined to
and the longer I stayed in school the
bigger my bill so I decided to drop out
seemed like the smartest thing to do at
the time I did I dropped out I took on
two jobs I started putting away a little
bit of money each month to pay the
school back but soon I realized this was
going to take forever and I was getting
collection calls at odd hours reminding
me that I'm running out of time to pay
the school back I didn't know what to do
there was a fight in me that I had to
admit to myself first that I couldn't do
this on my own then I realized I had to
admit it to other people because I had
to ask them for money and neither of
those things were things I wanted to do
but I had to if I wanted to be back in
school and soon I started having those
conversations that I dreaded and
something amazing happened friends and
family came out of nowhere to just offer
their help and say how can we help you
do what you want to do and it it didn't
take very long for them to connect me to
an incredible organization Runyon
scholarship foundation they gave me a
scholarship they put me right back in
school and I finished in three and a
half years with my class on time it felt
incredible and then once again when I
wanted to come to the GSB they were
there with the right advice mentorship
and it was with their relentless support
and my family
that I could be standing here talking to
you today the difference between my
story and Jake's story is that a
critical moment in our lives we both
needed help and one of us got it and the
other didn't that's it
and in that lies an important truth
about success that is about more than
hard work and perseverance that there is
something missing here and the missing
thing is support now support can come in
many shapes of forms it doesn't have to
be just financial support it could be
mentorship guidance just one critical
conversation can change the course of
someone's life now many of us feel that
we did it on our own but I'm willing to
bet if you look back and if you look
hard enough you'll find those moments
when you needed something you're looking
for advice or an answer to a question or
just somebody tell you everything's
going to be okay and someone stepped up
to help you and that made a huge
difference what if for millions of youth
like Jake
no one ever steps up what if someone
does someone like you or you are you
imagine all that potential realized
because each one of us decided here
today to beat a reason for someone's
success and here are three ways in which
you can do that one we talked about
support so when you tell the stories of
your successes talk about the people who
helped you get there talk about the
times you asked for help
and you got it so others have the
courage to do the same too we drop the
judgement as hiring managers
entrepreneurs and investors when you
come across someone like Jake and you
see an ambitious young person hungry for
more smart went to a good school
but maybe stumbled along the way a
little bit give them the benefit of the
doubt maybe you can change their life
with just one interview maybe you can
give them the break they need it all
along and three become a support asset
this could be serving as a mentor or
creating a scholarship fund or inventing
a new technology for discovering and
developing talent whatever it is get out
there today and find ways to support
others in their pursuit of success so we
can all live in a society where you have
hard work and perseverance you will get
the support you need to succeed thank
you
you